mesdames et messieurs bonjour vendredi
saint le jour des chemins de croix qui
rappelle le calvaire du christ 7 à
jérusalem tout au long des stations de
la via dolorosa que cette cérémonie
cette procession revel le plus d'ampleur
a si bien sûr que dans les pays les plus
catholiques tels l'espagne de nous
parvient cette photographie de la
procession de madrid ce matin en pleurs
à rome également où paul 6 porte une
croix de bois du mont palatin au colisée
avant de célébrer un service dans l'une
des bases inique de la ville éternelle
sainte marie majeure
quant aux sacrifices payen celui des
vacances quant aux rushs de pâques sur
les routes
il a commencé tôt ce matin les
officiants gardien de la sécurité sont
au nombre de 35 mille à pied crs et
gendarmes 6000 en moto ils sont assistés
de quelques 25 hélicoptères ils
préviendront il réprimeront avec l'aide
mécanique de près de 300 appareils de
mesure de vitesse instantanée pour
l'ensemble du pays
toute religion même la religion du duo
tôt n'est-elle pas un petit peu
répressives les fidèles bien sûr ce sont
les millions et les millions qui partent
sur les routes à la recherche du soleil
et d'un air un petit peu moins vicié que
celui des villes les sorties de la
capitale se faisait au ralenti
dès 8 heures dès 8h30 ce matin et cela
vaut un petit peu à l'échelle pour
toutes les villes importantes de france
et le temps est bien le plan de campagne
de la météo peut recevoir pour titre une
image emprunté à un roman de françoise
sagan un peu de soleil et de l'eau
froide de la météorologie nationale nous
allons avoir les précisions pour ce
week-end de pâques avec guy béland 12
d'ailleurs d'abord la tendance
d'ensemble monsieur béland 12 et bien
voici deux cartes c'est des cartes
représentent l'une la prévision pour
demain matin et la seconde pour dimanche
matin nous constatons tout d'abord que
notre pays reste sous l'influencé de
masse d'air très humide dirigé par ses
hautes pressions si pour demain tout
d'abord le corps plus vieux qui s'étend
actuellement sur le massif central et
les halles donnera quelques faibles
précipitations sur l'extrême sud est du
et demain matin à l'arrière nous aurons
un type de temps très nuageux gris un
peu comme nous avons connu ce matin et
avec des brouillards dans le sud-ouest
et brouillard se dissipant partiellement
l'après-midi et donnant quelques
éclaircies est ce que nous voyons
surtout c'est que nous avons un nouveau
système plus vieux qui s'étendra sur
l'ouest du pays et sur les régions
voisines de la manche au cours de la
journée l'ensemble s'est déplacé en
direction de l'est sud est c'est à dire
que la zone pluvieuse qui s'étendra de
qui prévue demain matin sur l'ouest du
pays
traversera au cours de la journée de
demain notre pays pour s'étendre
dimanche matin depuis l'est du massif
central au nord des alpes et au jura et
au nord-est immédiatement à l'arrière de
ce système plus vieux ce sera encore un
temps assez gris très nuageux à couvert
et ce sera tout de même une sorte d'
amélioration qui se développera dans
l'après midi
enfin ça ce sera donc pour dimanche
alors également y aura encore des
brouillards sur le sud-ouest mais il y
aura quand même du soleil sur plutôt sur
cette zone là disons que le temps gris
et très nuageux à couvert sera plus
localisé au nord de la loire
et comme ceux ci est ce qu'on peut dire
enfin sur en ce qui concerne lundi c'est
que lundi constituera une sorte d'
amélioration par rapport au temps que
nous avons connue donc demain et surtout
dimanche c'est à dire que l'amélioration
gagnera lentement par l'ouest en
direction de le massif central du
nord-est et de l'alsace mais ce ne sera
qu'une amélioration temporaire donc une
petite amélioration à prévoir dimanche
c'est le minimum de ce que l'on pouvait
espérer politique en france
l'entracte avant la bataille à khazar au
coeur de notre pays le président de la
république près par des discours le
premier ministre est en week-end
prolongé il a vu emporté lui aussi des
dossiers et la prochaine décision
relative au référendum et pour le 6
avril c'est celle des radicaux mais déjà
il tenait son peut dire que les cartes
sont répartis elles sont données
oui on peut faire le point des partisans
des différentes façons de voter le
ventre
avril dans le camp du non il n'y a qu'un
seul parti c'est le parti communiste qui
a fait connaître sa décision donc jeudi
dernier il ya maintenant une semaine
dans le camp de l'abstention on trouve
les socialistes qui ont appelé ça
d'ailleurs le refus de vote
on trouve toutes les organisations
gauchistes et trois pistes comme la
lutte ouvrière de monsieur kevin et la
ligue communiste de sucrine pardon et
aussi probablement le psu d'une fera
connaître sa décision que le 6 avril
mais il est très probable que le ps se
prononcera lui aussi pour l'abstention
former des radicaux il ya eu des
éléments nouveaux hier alors là on
rejoint le camp du oui il ya
naturellement toute la majorité ait eu
des airs républicains indépendants cdp
tous les petits partis alliés sur la
droite de la majorité
et puis sans doute depuis hier peut-on
penser que les radicaux et les
centristes de monsieur lequel vont
rejoindre le camp du oui en effet une
agence à lens reuter a publié le texte
de ce que pourrait être la question
posée aux français le 23 il ce texte
était celui ci approuvez-vous dans les
perspectives nouvelles qui s'ouvre à
l'europe
le projet de loi soumis au peuple
français par le président de la
république et autorisant la ratification
du traité relatif à l'adhésion de la
grande bretagne du danemark de l'irlande
et de la norvège aux communautés refait
c'est au conditionnel c'est surtout très
générationnel l'elysée n'a ni confirmé
ni démenti ce texte qui sera adopté
définitivement d'ailleurs par le conseil
des ministres mercredi prochain
mais quelle que soit la forme définitive
de ce texte on peut penser que dans le
fond dans l'esprit ce sera à peu près
100 en tout cas ça voudra dire la même
chose dans tous les cas l'europe
uniquement et c'est ce qui amène les
centristes et à la naissance et un oral
jeunes qu'annuelle 17 caisses si la
question n'a pas de caractère
publicitaire
si on ne demande pas d'approuver toute
la politique du gouvernement si on ne
parle que de l'europe et bien je ne peux
que donner un avis dans un sens
favorable et monsieur sallanches reiber
lui dit je crois que monsieur pompidou a
maintenant la volonté d'aller plus loin
dans la construction de l'europe donc je
lui dirais probablement oui si cette
question correspond à ce qu'on a annoncé
hier mais maintenant c'est bien
l'entracte que j'avais annoncé
l'entracte on démarre mardi avec la
rentrée parlementaire et toute une série
de réunions politiques des divers partis
mercredi et jeudi prochains merci ni
autre chose l'aveyron dans l'aveyron le
philosophe lanza del vasto en est au 12e
jour du jeune qu'il observe jusqu'à
dimanche pour protester contre
l'extension possible du camp militaire
du larzac lanza del vasto est un
pacifiste convaincu
il vient d'écrire au président de la
république pour lui demander
d'intervenir
afin d' éviter l'expropriation des
agriculteurs de la région
il y à 48 heures les évêque de rodez et
de montpellier avaient pris position
dans le même sens contre la décision
d'extension prise par le ministre de la
guerre la vie de lanza del vasto tel
qu'il a été recueillies par le
correspondant de montpellier la chose me
regarde de très de très près car c'est
un devoir de bon voisinage nous habitons
notre communauté est installé dans les
environs et nous considérons que chez
notre devoir d'intervenir
vous pensez qu'en la matière donc pour
cette affaire de leurs actes il y a
véritablement arbitraire là il n'y a eu
aucune consultation des habitants du
pays au moment où ils ont appris leur
malheur par la radio les le conseil
général du département
à l'unanimité les syndicats les
organisations professionnelles l'église
par la voix de l'évêque de rodez et par
le mouvement chrétien dans le dans le
monde rural ont donné leur marque et
leur totale opposition à l'extension du
camp qui est un désastre pour la région
vous allez donc faire quinze jours de
jeu ici pour les agriculteurs du larzac
une fois que vous aurez terminé si
satisfaction n'a pas été donnée
que croyez vous qu'ils pourraient être
faits à au cas où
au cas où on voudrait les chasser par
force alors j'appellerai de tous les
coins de france des milliers et des
milliers de jeunes gens et des milliers
de moins jeunes pour se mettre en
travers de l'opération sans cris ni
violence je ne sais pas si le pouvoir
est prêt à s' il est conciliable pour
lui de provoquer un scandale énorme mais
content aussi les basques de
l'organisation autonomie stone bata le
préfet des pyrénées atlantiques vient
d'interdire la célébration sur la voie
publique de la fête nationale basque
dans les rues de mauléon nos libertés
publiques des
les basques se limite à jouer à la
pelote à danser le fandango et à chanter
dans notre langue
riposte laine bata préconise le boycott
de tous les spectacles du dimanche de
pâques à saint-jean-de-luz
les marins pêcheurs attire l'attention
sur leurs problèmes en déversant des
macros dans les principales artères de
la ville ainsi il y avait près de 20
tonnes de maquereaux pêle-mêle devant la
mairie hier après midi à saint jean on a
dû reporter l'ouverture de la campagne
de pêche à l'anchois
le prix du maquereau est tombée aux
alentours de 80 centimes le kilo et il
ya trop d'importations
voilà les motifs de la protestation des
pêcheurs basse ce qui augmente le prix
du lait au détail à partir de lundi + 9
centimes ce qui mettra le litre
pasteurisé à paris à un franc 13 en
bouteilles consignées la majoration qui
intervient suit la hausse du prix du
lait chez les producteurs qui a été
décidée à bruxelles il ya une semaine
pour l'instant pas de majoration des
produits dérivés du yaourts du beurre
pour l'instant en hausse également les
transports de marchandises décision
parue au journal officiel de ce matin
transport par la sncf 3,8 pour cent de
plus et pour les colis express 7 7%
transport routier à partir de lundi +38
également et une deuxième étape de
hausse le 1er juillet 1,2 pour cent
c'est en deux crans pour les transports
routiers en un seul pour les transports
par rail pour les voyageurs en ce qui
concerne le rail
rien n'a été décidé mais on prévoir et
une augmentation dans le courant de
l'année drogue suite de notre enquête à
marseille
petit trafiquant vendeurs de neige et
d'illusions marseille
22h en plan du côté de l'opéra avec une
équipe de la brigade des stupéfiants
quatre interpellations de drogués trois
arrestations de revendeurs d'héroïne en
moins d'une heure
chaque nuit
c'est le même scénario des acteurs ce
soir honte à peine 20 ans ça y est tu
l'as acheté comme ce cas la jeune fille
se piquent huit fois par jour à
l'héroïne
le garçon lui est un revendeur les
boutons de coincer par tout ce que tu
fais dans la vie est plus chère
les pêcheurs et on affine est tellement
toujours forte et brandon et le nouvel
oiseau tu continues à te faire
photographier promenait détenus
artistique chinois huawei toi comment
justement des photos en couleurs on
connaît sur l'aprilia dernière fois
ce matin inquiétudes serpe
ok tu te sers tu pleures à fils
remercie le bon dieu de tout et fait
sauter ce soir à la normale pour la
première fois espèce de couilles en
remercie le bon dieu est au fait arrêter
au moins tu vois pas un peu à quoi ça
mène tu as vu ton pote a marqué les
tailles les remercie le bon dieu [ __ ]
même allant pas possible ça
il
à
homo
le lieu de rendez vous de ces drogués
des revendeurs qui souvent sont
eux-mêmes toxicomanes certains bars ou
boîtes de nuit du vieux-port de l'opéra
ou des paniers une première mesure à
marseille
la fermeture systématique des
établissement acceptant ce petit trapu
nous avons déterminé au cours d' enquête
que dans certains établissements on
était vraiment trop tolérants envers les
trafiquants et je crois que chaque fois
que nous aurons pu déterminer que ces
établissements acceptent que
on s'intoxiquent chez eux nous les
frapperons comme des skis donc nous ne
devons pas
accepter que ces rendez-vous que les
religions puissent avoir comme cela des
lieux de rendez vous ils sont certains
de trouver de la drogue et où les
trafiquants savent trouver de
l'intoxication ne sera pas poursuivi on
va l'hospitaliser le revendeur lui
risque deux ans de prison
effectivement le nombre des jeunes
intoxiqués dans la région aix marseille
est extrêmement important et il n'est
pas question de les poursuivre
pénalement ni à plus forte raison de
faire prononcer à leur égard des
condamnations pénales
l'or car relève essentiellement de la
santé publique
le voyage aérien est au centre d'une
nouvelle petite guerre
à partir de demain 1er avril
l'association internationale des
transporteurs lieta instaure un régime
de libre concurrence pour les prix des
transports aériens entre l'europe le
proche orient et l'afrique d'une part
l'asie et le pacifique d'autre part tout
cela parce que plusieurs compagnies
n'ont pas approuvé les derniers accords
de tarifs mise au point laborieusement
d'ailleurs pour essayer de lutter contre
les compagnies de charters accord en
revanche entre air france et la bea pour
les liaisons entre la france et la
grande bretagne en respectant certaines
règles quant aux vols est accessible
quand à la réservation
on pourra à partir du 10 avril effectué
l'aller retour paris londres pour 194
francs je dis bien là les retourner deux
trajets le prix de l'aller-retour
normale qui est de 3 146 francs
actuellement passera à 390 francs
mais à 194 francs paris nombre et retour
l'avion est moins cher qu'une autre un
deuxième classe qui revient à 205 francs
via calais le train plus bien sûr le
passage en ferry boat cette même
politique des prix ab sera également les
tarifs entre la province française et
londres de 40% interdite en france
madame très peur le ministère de
l'intérieur refusé son visa dans près l
épouse de l'ancien chef du réseau
soviétique d'espionnage baptisée l'
orchestre rouge
monsieur très peur non nous avons parlé
à plusieurs reprises vite en pologne et
ne peut pas en sortir son épouse qui est
ici à ses côtés vient d'obtenir un
passeport de la part des autorités
polonaises il ya de cela une douzaine de
jours elle va se rendre à copenhague où
réside l'un de ses fils
mais à paris du fait de poursuites
engagées par la justice française dans
les années 40 la famille très père fait
l'objet d'un arrêté d'interdiction de
séjour
un rappel du drame de la conclusion du
drame de turquie les trois otages
britanniques de l'armée populaire de
libération aux turcs sont morts hier
dans la maison proche du village de nix
arcs où il était détenu
on voit ici leurs trois corps calcinés
tels qu'ils ont été découverts par la
police
mais le mystère plane toujours sur la
façon dont s'est déroulé le drame
explosion générale extradition suicides
dus aux guérilleros zh
ou bien exécution des trois otages par
les membres du commando gauchistes
lesquels on te même été tués après par
les forces de sécurité on voit ici le
cadavre de l'un des responsables il
s'agit de 6 jan
halte est clean qui avec majorque à yann
s'était déjà rendu tristement célèbre il
ya un an
en enlevant et en exécutant le consul
général d'israël à ankara
les deux terroristes avaient réussi à
s'échapper de prison pendant leur procès
il compte désormais au nombre des dix
ravisseurs qui ont trouvé la mort hier
dans cet assaut final d'une tragique
aventure en argentine à plus de 2 jours
de l'expiration du délai fixé par les
ravisseurs de monsieur salustro toujours
aucun signe de vie du directeur local de
la fia la police n'a trouvé aucune trace
jusque là on voit ici 250 kg de dynamite
découvert pendant les fouilles pendant
les investigations mais pas de piste
sérieuse pour l'industriel les sports
maintenant avec alain billoin est tout
d'abord ce qui est sans doute une suite
aux résultats de football que nous
donnions ici-même cuillères à thé limite
au 29e jour du championnat marseille est
tombé sur son terrain devant bastia et
c'est sans doute une suite voilà que ce
matin on apprend que le duc l'entraîneur
de l'om est limogé oui c'est une
information que nous avons reçue tout à
fait en fin de matinée et pour le moment
le secrétariat de l'olympique de
marseille se refuse à toute déclaration
il a néanmoins précisé que ce soir le
comité directeur de l'om se réuniraient
et étudierait cette question on ne sait
pas si c'est un mouvement d'humeur ou
une décision profonde ce que l'on peut
constater en tous les cas c'est que
depuis que le duc étaient aux côtés des
athées lee était devenu l'entraîneur de
l'om l'équipe ne s'est pas si mal
défendu elle a été battue par bastia sur
son terrain ils ont tous les marseillais
réussissent mal contre les corses mais
si c'est vraiment une décision qui suit
la défaite de l'om devant les corses se
semble peut-être un petit peu exagéré
oui en fait il s'agirait d'un différend
entre le président de l'olympique de
marseille marcel leclerc et lucien leduc
ces différents remonterait d'ailleurs au
match de coupe d'europe de football
contre l'ajax
il est évident que les récentes
contre-performances de l'olympique de
marseille face à montluçon déjà en coupe
de france
et puis tout récemment vous disiez
contre bastia et bien ils ont un petit
peu précipité les choses
oui parfois je veux pas me faire
l'avocat du diable sealyham l'igname et
contre performances alors connais
l'équipe en tête avec sept points
d'avancé c'est tout de même bizarre
comme le vocabulaire qu'on peut employer
bruit c'est juste un tout afin
d'anticiper ont pas on verra ce que dit
l'om au comité directeur ce soir zatelli
qui était conseiller technique prend
sans doute en charge vient c'est ça qui
nous a dit qu'un ce matin au stade
vélodrome et bien les joueurs de
l'olympique de marseille se sont
entraînés normalement
lucien leduc était là il a d'ailleurs
fait une déclaration il a dit je
regrette de ne pouvoir conduire l'om
jusqu'à la fin du championnat mais c'est
mario zatelli qui a dirigé
l'entraînement des joueurs de marseille
on verra ce soir sans doute le pasteur à
télescope pour hâter voudrait plus de
détails passons à neuf box avec cassius
clay il prépare sa revanche contre
phrase hier et qui va disputer un match
au japon oui c'est ça c'est un combat
entre cassius clay et max master c'est
un combat important pour les deux hommes
car l'un et l'autre aimerait rencontrer
et jouer phrase hier pour le titre de
champion
qu'un suspect vient nous retrouvons
maintenant à l'entraînement à tokyo un
pied un petit peu en pâte ont d'ailleurs
il fait actuellement 106 kg contre 96 kg
nan parce qu'elle est bien une reste un
inimitable comédien et il faut en gros
il va jouer à ravir son rôle d'amuseur
public vous êtes voir bientôt
c'est un très bon boxeur dont le
comédien visant un geste a alors quel
suspect il est en culotte blanche là il
a pour sparring partner georges
partenaires qui veulent envoyer tout à
l'heure au tapis vous allez voir mais
encore il s'agit d'un petit gag fai pour
appliquer sur tous les témoins en fait
quel est ton bras sur une glissade mike
foster est un boxeur l'est et répugnant
a déclaré casus mais alan dont il parle
trop je vais lui clouer le bec aux 5e
rhône il est rare au tapis pour le
compte
et bien la creuse terre lui a répondu
que l'état prétentieux j'ai gagné mes
trente derniers combats par ko il sort à
la 31ème vif qui pour le ca fait parler
le parti du folklore habituel
ce qui est moins pauvre l'oryx et le
montant des bourses oui bien le montant
des bourses pour ce combat cas suspects
touchera la coquette somme de 182
millions d'anciens francs et mcmaster se
contentera si l'on peut dire de 40
millions d'anciens
maintenant vous allez voir pelé
tournoyer autour de son sparring
partners est une petite danse en
sautillant qui entrent dans les
caractéristiques de son style ici il
harangue la foule qu est-ce qui se plaît
précisons que le combat se déroulera
cette nuit et là vous voyez un petit peu
chahuté le présentateur de la télévision
japonaise
non il vaut mieux qu'ils soient là bas
qu'ici il ya quand même du muscle en
réserve
basket du muscle s'il ya de la taille un
international qui mesure deux mètres 12
dans l'équipe de france ça se voit pas
souvent
il s'appelle roger du quesnoy il faut
dire que c'est un ancien rugbyman est
théoriquement à cognac et avec ses 120
kg et faisait pas mal de performances
sur les terrains de rugby mais voilà
maintenant en basket
oui on fait appel à lui et peut-être à
peu tardivement il a disputé hier soir
un match contre la suisse et il a marqué
19 points c'est donc très encourageant
pour ce garçon qui pourrait entrer dans
l'équipe olympique française pour les
jeux olympiques qui se dérouleront vous
savez au mois de sept ans il est ici il
a 23 ans il s'appelle du quesnoy et donc
il a contribué à ce succès de la suisse
la suisse gagne le sud de la france que
ce que je dis la france a gagné assez
largement je croyais ans 84 à 5 ans il
est bon de préciser que ce n'est pas la
première fois qu à gyan entre dans
l'équipe de france il ya une dizaine
d'années il y avait jean claude lefebvre
qui avait réussi de très bons matches
qui avait été sélectionnée d'ailleurs 30
fois en équipe de france
mais jean-claude de fer qui mesurait
deux mètres 17 il est bon de le préciser
et qui n'était pas le basketteur le plus
grand du monde puisque les soviétiques
ont eu également il ya une dizaine
d'années un joueur qui mesurait deux
mètres 30 d' agir et pas jusqu'à dire
que du quesnoy avec ses 2 mètres 12 août
un petit garçon avec rosie morel
maintenant mesdames hebdo santé comment
conserver les jambes de vos 20 ans
hilary sont extrêmement fréquents très
étendue il y as à 15 ans à peu près
les médecins et des chirurgiens n'était
absolument pas d'accord car les uns
opérait uniquement et les autres
pratiquer ce qu'on appelle la méthode
sclérosante des roses et les varices
mais le depuis l'amélioration au des
deux techniques
maintenant nous sommes à peu près à ce
si dans un même résultat et tantôt
lorsque les varices sont importantes il
faut les opérer et tantôt lorsque les
varices sont moins importantes ou après
une intervention chirurgicale
il faut l'espérer osé qdvp par sclérosé
la cité rose c'est simplement
l'injection à très faible quantité d'un
liquide dans une parisse et qui a pour
but d'irriter la partie interne de la
veine de façon qu'elles se referme sur
elle-même et qu'elle empêche le courant
contraire de se déverser dans la
périphérie est ce que cette opération ne
nuit pas à la circulation locale dans la
jambe
nous sommes ne gêne absolument pas la
circulation la jambe bien au contraire
puisque les varices gêne cette
circulation donc par conséquent que l'on
fasse un traitement ste rose ans ou un
traitement chirurgical
nous devons théoriquement obtenir
toujours un bon résultat
il existe un domaine du traitement
chirurgical des varices et ce domaine
correspond à la veine qui est situé sous
la peau à la face interne de la cuisse
cette veine dans laquelle normalement le
sang circule de la périphérie vers le
centre se met à fonctionner à contre
courant dans la maladie varient que
cette veine constitue la voie
d'alimentation principale c'est-à-dire
un paquet variqueux à la face interne du
jeu trop on a rêvé que la crosse et on a
retiré la veine malade à ce moment là le
paquet ne reçoit plus l'essentiel de son
alimentation et le médecin interviendra
à ce moment là pour le stère osé dans
les meilleures conditions cette sclérose
après stripping qui est complémentaire
de la chirurgie amènera de la guérison
complète
quand on parle des varices on pense
surtout à deux formes de varices les
varices professionnels et les varices de
la grossesse
est-ce qu'elle pose des problèmes
particuliers oui
il y a quand même d'une part une
hérédité varie que ce qui est certaine
d'autre part sur un terrain prédisposés
du fait des fonctions que l'on soit
dentistes kinésithérapeutes par exemple
cuisinier coiffeur on peut avoir une
augmentation de ses varices alors
qu'elle pouvait être pratiquement
insignifiantes elles peuvent à ce moment
là se développer d'une façon
considérable et les varices de la
grossesse alors les bariseau la
profession tout à fait différent parce
que ce gars là un mécanisme endocriniens
qui joue plus les mécanismes mécanique
et ses varices peut se développer
quelquefois très rapidement au début de
la grossesse et se développer
normalement je crois que il faut bien
dire aux jeunes femmes et qui voit
apparaître de très importantes varices
ou membres inférieurs au cours de leur
grossesse qu'elle ne se ferait pas trop
parce que un grand nom de ses varices
disparaîtront
après l'accouchement et que de toute
façon on pourra faire un traitement
pendant cette période de la grossesse
la contention par ba ou par bandes si
cela est nécessaire et la meilleure
solution
je crois que vous êtes capable depuis
une date relativement récent d'attaqué
de très très très très fine varie ce
qu'on appelle les cartes de géographie
oui sûrement en homme c est en termes
techniques ce sont les télés injecté si
c'était l'injecter asie qui apparaissent
qui sont plutôt visible et disgracieux
chez la jeune femme sans situer à la
face externe dit qu'ils soient là face à
un tel est effectivement au point de vue
technique nous ne pouvions pas le faire
il ya quelques temps mais maintenant
nous pouvons faire un traitement en
injectant cet élan j'ai quasi et en les
réduisant est ce qu'il ya une diététique
particulière à suivre la diététique oui
c'est à dire que le facteur poids joue
énormément mais si le facteur poids joue
énormément je crois qu'il faudrait
d'abord insister davantage insisté que
si nous voyons peut-être moins de
varices maintenant qu'il y a quelques
années c'est parce qu'on arrive à mieux
les traiter
mais que notre part il est sûrement
davantage de maïs maintenant car on ne
sait plus marcher et c'est la marche qui
est quand même le moyen le meilleur de
l'après
je crois qu'il faut ajouter quelques
notions pratiques à l'opinion des
spécialistes les hommes aussi ont des
varices ils ont deux fois moins que les
femmes et non à cause de l'ascenseur la
voiture le bureau il ne marche pas ça
c'est chez les femmes il y a des causes
prédisposant sova harris qui ont disparu
la jarretière qui serrait les gens il y
en a d'autres qui sont de mode c'est le
soleil et le soleil est dangereux il
conditionne les vaisseaux sanguins
il favorise l'apparition des varices
tandis que marcher dans l'eau jusqu'aux
mollets est une excellente pratique il
faut marcher
il faut éviter certains sports par
exemple le tennis par exemple le volley
ball sur un sol dur mais sur le sable
est acceptable par exemple le basket
ball ou le ping pong
il ya un autre ennemi des jambes qui par
certains côtés d'un ami c'est le massage
les massages assez violent qu'on fait
pour effacer les cellulites et qui en
pétrissant la chair peut faire éclater
les petits vaisseaux et causé ces
miniatures varie ce qu'on appelle les
varicosités qui ressemblent à des cartes
de géographie qui sont inesthétiques que
vol les cures thermales et bien il ne
faut pas attendre de miracle les cures
thermales ne guérissent pas les varices
mais elle soulage et elles sont à la
pointe précis aux thérapeutiques
j'ai noté que le ski n'est pas interdit
parmi les sports pour essayer de lutter
contre ce mal et léo lacroix qui est au
rendez vous du vendredi de télé midi
avec la cause d'enneigement des stations
de france et certainement d'accord avec
ce verdict de rosie morin alors comment
ça va en montagne à de la neige et du
soleil est d'ailleurs pas mal de neige
et du soleil d'ailleurs je peux vous
rentrez également des sports d'hiver
trois coups même une très bonne mine
alors on a tellement de travail tout le
monde s'en voir là qu'un tarif aux
clients et qui respecte le bio dans les
alpes du nord en savoie haute savoie et
dans l'isère
il fait très beau donc ces derniers
temps ce qui explique comme vous allez
pouvoir le constater comme constaté
d'ailleurs succès et panneaux que la
hauteur de neige est relativement faible
mais malgré tout on skie dans toutes les
stations
je vous conseille donc de skins et où le
matin c'est leur idéal pour sortir des
pistes est ce qui est justement sur la
neige qui est transformé c'est aussi la
période du ski en altitude
oui également jusqu'à l'altitude tout
particulièrement la dépose sur glacier
je vous signale que de nombreuses
citations organise au départ de leur
halte yport des vols et des balades sur
glace ils ne l'ont nous rendant film aux
trente ans dit le sauze dessus de la
station du soc mais également du super
sauze d'ailleurs il ya deux stations il
ya le super sauze dans les alpes du sud
dans la rue grenet dubai c'est pas loin
de barcelone est tout proche de
boisseaux launay de 3 km 500 seulement
sept stations toutes les joies de la
montagne
été comme hiver le saut situé à 400
mètres d'altitude
le super sauze à 17 100 possède un
domaine ce qui est très diversifiée 45
km de pistes balisées
un équipement comportant treize téléski
et un télésiège qui dessert 22 bis très
bien entretenue grâce aux engins
mécaniques son école de ski compte 28
moniteur 5 jardinières de neige et une
garderie d'enfants le sauze avec 17
hôtels de nombreux chats les immeubles à
une capacité totale d'hébergement de 90
en plus de ces hôtels le soc possède un
camping caravaning de 300 places pour
vous distraire au centre de la station
d'innate le ca de jeu cinéma patinoire
tennis ainsi qu'un club hippique
le sauze la plus ancienne station de
sports d'hiver de la vallée de l'ubaye à
de nombreux projets d'extension en
direction de la montagne de la halle le
resteront la vallée de la tinée ainsi
que l'aménagement du quartier de la
renta super sauze à super sauze oui si
vous allez au saut vous rencontrerez
sûrement deux figures de la station
monsieur coutelas et mon ami benoît
lisons dans les alpes du sud les
pyrénées le massif central l'enneigement
est encore très bon comme vous allez
pouvoir le constater en regardant les
panneaux qui vont suivre
mais en même temps on pourrait parler
des manifestations pour léo lacroix leur
effectivement menuires le 9 avril aura
d'une première inédite vol à skis qui
marquera l'ouverture d'ailleurs de la
première école de vol à ski au monde à
courchevel 2 avril au cours de la fête
des moniteurs aura lieu une compétition
de soi que la participation des équipes
nationales suisse d'allemagne et de
france et où deux alpes depuis le 29
mars à station a mise en service donc on
déshabille remontées mécaniques qui
permettant à pratiquer du ski d'été
un téléphérique automoteurs du genre
riel télésiège de la torah qui culmine à
3000 m d'altitude
un record a été battu à la plagne
téléski effet conçu en trois jours
alexandre chef pour remplacer le
télécabine détruit par un incendie
et bien maintenant je vous souhaite à
tous de très bonnes fêtes de pâques et
j'espère que vous profiterez au maximum
de vos derniers jours de ski on a
rappelé et vous étés l'horloge des
neiges et puis on va terminer en donnant
les saints et les saintes du jour
benjamin et amos nage à miner balbine
benjamin diacre qui en lan 420
accompagné à son évêque martyrs c'était
en perse
il avait été arrêté après l'incendié
d'un temple païen dédié au culte du feu
je voudrais préciser que si ce télé midi
a eu un cadre un peu inhabituel c'est à
la suite de la poursuite de la grève des
chefs de production dont je vous parlais
hier qui amèneront quelques
perturbations et programmes ça c'est du
domaine de lys fabre je voudrais aussi
qu'il n'ya pas de bourse aujourd'hui ni
demain ni lundi il n'y a que des oeufs
de pâques dans la corbeille de vidal
anges de tardieu de nos amis boursiers
et boursicoter bon après midi